en mettant ça dans un pas
constitutionnel on peut avoir peur que
mais ça lanterne
fragilise parce que et pourquoi mélanger
ça avec je sais pas moi l'allongement
durée de du mandat présidentiel la
réforme des territoires enfin on voit ça
n'a aucun sens donc vous demandez voilà
et puis moi je demande rien du tout
parce que ce droit n'était pas menacé et
franchement voilà alors en plus ça va
créer une autre difficulté imaginons que
ce texte soit soit voté qu'est-ce qui va
se passer alors soit c'est une liberté
ok mais pourquoi réviser la Constitution
pour ça et pas pour le reste je rappelle
quand même que les républicains avaient
demandé une révision de la Constitution
pour renforcer la laïcité en disant nul
ne peut se prévaloir de ses croyances
etc pour donc c'était la formulation de
Philippe Bas et de Bruno retaillod donc
pourquoi ne pas ça aussi donc ça va
réouvrir un débat donc le fait de
réouvrir un débat ça peut fragiliser le
vote ou alors sur le dos de l'IVG si je
puis dire Emmanuel Macron s'achète un
consensus qu'il est incapable de trouver
ailleurs donc j'avoue que je comprends
pas bien trop la manip
ni au départ parce que c'est une sorte
d'américanisation de la société
et aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que le
Parlement est décédé de ce texte tout à
fait clairement puisque c'est à
l'initiative résidentielle donc la balle
est dans le camp d'Emmanuel Macron on va
voir ce que ça va donner